all right hello everyone and welcome to
the first ever hello webinar with me
i've got leif ostrand hello
hello
and you are if i'm not mistaken the one
of the product managers behind hillary
that's absolutely right it was almost
with me it started but then i've been
doing a whole bunch of other things in
between but
now i'm back here again to talk about it
and huge congratulations on getting it
out i know it's been kind of a long time
coming and it's
been kind of included in the modern
platform for a for a while but now it's
kind of its own thing
yeah and because of that i think
it was kind of worth for us to have this
live stream and just talk about
why
you personally thought that the world
needed another
framework
uh since there are so many from before
so can i just dig into the ideas behind
why we built hilla in the first place
and
of course because we are developers and
we're talking to i assume mostly
developers we're going to tell this
story mostly through code
so anyway do you want to get us started
and just share a little bit of the
history behind
uh hitler and how it came to be and what
kind of problems we're solving with it
yeah that's
that sounds like an excellent plan
so yeah we it it was kind of
we we at whatever we have been building
a
web application development framework
for
almost or over 20 years already
but we were also thinking kind of
maybe we should do something different
no that wasn't really how it was but we
we observed that
because vardin is
only for for developers who use only
java but with we were also seeing that
lots of people preferred to mix of
course front-end and back-end
technologies so from that we kind of
started thinking about
what what could we contribute to that
space and uh because the one thing that
we have that is
quite our own thing is that we very much
focus on
uh development developer productivity
and i will see more about that when we
actually dig into the code also
so
maybe you should just get started with
kicking off a hilla project
i will do that if you want to
explain to us meanwhile what a hilla is
and what it has to do with vardins
yeah so hila is
uh
i know it's a cloudberry that's the
english name of it so it's it's it's one
of the native berries that live and live
grow here in in the forest in finland
and we are also otherwise advising from
finland and for instance our logo with
the
with the angle and and curly braces
that's actually also represents a
reindeer and so on so we kind of a
little bit go back to our finished roots
also with the name of
of this framework
yeah
they definitely live in the same place
up up north both the cloud berries and
and the reindeer alright so what i'm
thinking that we would do here is we're
going to use the cli to just create a
new project and then we're just going to
walk through a different couple
different
things here and as we go through them
maybe like you can give a little bit of
like a director's commentary on
what we're seeing why things work that
specific way and
and of course if we have any questions
coming in from the audience as we're
doing this we'll we'll try to answer so
i'm going to kick start the project
creation here we're creating a new app
and it's going to be called a grocery
app we're going to cd into the
into the folder here
and i'm going to open it with vs code so
just type in code
that
and then
i'm going to go ahead and use the
included maven
wrapper
to start it so the default
target is is just starting the included
spring boot application
and
then if we go to localhost on port 8080
we'll see that there is a front-end
development build running here
and
once that finishes we have the
application up and running obviously not
a whole lot here to see right now
i think
since we're living on the edge here i
want to
make a small change here already so i'm
going to use vit here for front end
development can you briefly explain what
i just did and why somebody might want
to do that
yeah so so what you did was that you
enabled a feature flag that's for an
experimental feature that we believe is
ready enough to be used but there's
still some rough edges that we're
finalizing but the whole point of using
vit for for the front-end build is just
that it's
it's very very fast to incrementally
react to any changes we do
good
all right and i'm i'm very happy i
actually remember to bump up the font
size here in my app before we started
coding and everyone complained they
can't see anything so as i'm looking at
the project here um
something strikes me like obviously
it's one project but it has this
front-end folder but then it has the
standard maven source main java folder
here
so can you talk a little bit about
this whole setup
yeah we will actually i think we'll come
back to that also later when we
look at code examples but really one of
the
core ideas we have with with hila is
that
front-end development and
server back-end development
they
kind of fit together because
it just makes things easier that we will
see down the line and and that has
actually been one of the central things
around hillar kind of how can we benefit
from allowing them to be good together
even though conventional wisdom is that
they should be separated but there's
also different opinions on how much
sense that makes
yeah i mean you can definitely see a
kind of a strong opinion in in the
contrary to what maybe many people
assume how your
quote-unquote supposed to build uh
client-side applications where you have
a very strict separation between your
back-end whether that's a rest service
or a graphql or something and then
you're front-end so
what we claim and what we believe is
that by having these two things live in
the same project then kind of assume
that they're going to be tightly
integrated will allow us to make a lot
of things easier that would be quite
difficult when you have these two things
as completely separate
that's right and well
half of the point here is just to show
to show what goes on there so i think we
should start with something really
really simple
uh because very much about what what we
have with gila is
how do you again combine this
server-side java and
and client-side
javascript or actual typescript that
we're using so uh
that's where about communication between
server and
and clients so let's create a grocery
endpoint because well this is a grocery
example
but first we could just do a really
simple hello world so if you add just
endpoint annotation there
and then anonymous allowed also to
just for this example bypass the the
security checks uh yeah to make things
easier yeah i think it's good to kind of
point out that by default all endpoints
kind of block access and you have to
explicitly tell who should be able to
access an endpoint just so
the default is secure in a way yeah and
that also means that just by looking at
this class you immediately know what's
the access control for it you don't need
to dig through any
any kind of separate configurations or
anything
but yeah let's let's do a hello world we
already started so
yeah we get in
a message string and then we return
another string which is just well server
says and they then it goes back the
thing
very very uh advanced stuff here yep
and so you want to just start with a
console log before we get to too far
let's do things really simple here so in
the index
index ts file it's got a bunch of other
things to set up routing and so on but
we won't look at those now yeah but yeah
what we can do now when we have that
endpoint because again we we only
combine
the java and
the typescript so based on the java
class we have we generate a typescript
thing that you can import also that we
have there right now
so if you just import that one
and then on that immediately
we get
automatically with type completion we
get the method
that we define on the circle see this
takes in a string
world
because what else would i say
yeah
and then
that thing returns
uh can we use top level await in this
context
no
so well we'll get to that in the when we
get to the view but i think the the
thing to take away from here is that the
communication is asynchronous by and
non-blocking by nature so when we call
the server we're not kind of blocking
the ui for that we can
wait for something to happen and then we
can react to that
we'll get
a
you get a message and then call back
that just console log
that message i guess yeah that's easy
enough
right and then
obviously we need to open up the console
yeah
and sure enough the server says
hello world
yes so
we went from here
to our endpoint
and back
but what was pretty cool is that if we
look at what we
imported here we
just imported this generated
thing so it looks in the typescript code
like we're calling a typescript method
but over
kind of magically behind the scenes
we're actually going over the wire and
and and calling the server so that's
pretty neat
all right do you want to build something
more meaningful or are we happy with
this uh i i could maybe make a couple of
kind of architects observations from
this also
uh because well like i already said this
is really it's creating coupling between
your client side and your server side
code
but uh one of the things we have been
observing is that communication over the
network
that's already difficult enough on its
own we don't need to introduce any
additional
kind of complications there also so
in that way we we believe in in this
architectural pattern called uh back
ends for frontends bff you can also set
its best best friends forever
that
the whole idea is that
your back end the kind of topmost layer
so to say of your back end
could and should be customized to your
uh client-side need if you have multiple
different clients like you have a web
client and you have
i don't know a mobile client then you
have maybe some some third-party
integrations and and whatnot then each
of them probably has slightly different
needs also for what exactly how how they
request things and so on
and that's why
that's why it makes sense to make each
of them
as a separate thing and also so that
it's um
it's kind of it's the team that builds
the front end they also maintain the
topmost layer of the back end if they if
you want to you can have full feature
kind of full-blown feature teams that
own the whole stack for each use case
but you can also have it so that the
front-end team
if you have separate front-end teams
that is that the front-end team is
responsible for the very top-most
part of the server-side layer and then
all the services and so on that you use
from that
from that kind of back end layer that
can then be be kind of managed by the
actual back-end team so to say
sure so i mean to bring things to a more
concrete level you're saying that the
front-end team would essentially
build this endpoint that we're looking
at here and it would then call services
that are
could be provided by either
back in person in the same team or a
separate back-end team maybe even
exactly
yeah that makes sense i mean
all of that
sounds very good as a lazy developer
what makes me very happy is that i get
auto-complete on all the method names
and
signatures so i don't like typo things
and obviously when i change something
that that gets reflected
yeah so um
let's jump into the the front end here
and i think since we're building a
grocery app applets
i think what we'll need is some kind of
form to enter
grocery items and then we probably need
some place to kind of display them right
yeah to view your shopping list also but
let's start with just the form
so can you tell us what we're looking at
right now
we are looking at well obviously the
growth review typescript uh file uh it's
it's a class uh and it uses uh lit
as the rendering library so um
it it's a way of doing web components so
every view on your application is a
separate web component so here we have
grocery that's view dash view that's
actually if you open the dom inspector
you will see that there is
an element with that
name somewhere hiding there inside main
layout inside growth review yeah so what
we're looking at is the implementation
of that custom html element and that is
then the view that that
that we see
yeah
and
you might be wondering here also kind of
what's the point with with these web
components what the point with
with
with you using lit for rendering and and
the point is where that web components
they're really universal
you can use the same component
with basically any front end library
rendering library and the other way
you're all way around also we at
whatever we are building one set of web
components but you can just as well
either use our web components with some
other library or the other way around
use
use hila with some other set of web
components if you want
while you're
talking i'll i'll start importing some
of the ones that i think will
so i think one of the strengths of hilla
is that not only do you get this full
stack thing
uh framework that combines the front end
and the back end but you also get this
library of of components that make
just building these professional looking
uis pretty pretty fast
so i'll take the
body number field because we'll have a
kind of
the item that we're adding how many of
those and then we'll have a
button
and now i see there's a question online
roland krueger is asking on what is
typescript code generation based does it
use java byte code or is it based on the
source code like for instance the grid
cross compiler
actually the version we're seeing right
now uses uh java parses java code
but we're actually for the very for the
next version we are
building a new parser generator uh thing
that instead uses primarily byte code
but it also supplements with reading
java for instance for getting uh if you
have javadocs on your endpoint method
methods then it also makes that
into the typescript and in that way you
can you can see more about what you
kind of get more information there but
so today it uses java code but
very soon uh maybe uh three months from
now i think based on the roadmap we
would have a version that actually uses
bytes code instead as the primary thing
and that for instance makes it possible
to have have multi-module support in a
sensible way it makes it possible to use
kotlin if you prefer that also
yeah that sounds really really excited
exciting so while you were talking i
added three components here one text
field number filled in a button
and they showed up here shut up yeah
probably a slightly confusing place
and that's because of
all this configuration or these helper
classes that we had here so we'll
remove the centering here
great
makes more sense
all right and then i'll also add that
volume grid here and we'll we'll get
back to that when we actually have some
data but
of course for this to be a meaningful
app we probably need to have some kind
of back end for it where we can actually
save
save our grocery list
i agree
good so uh
that's one observation that
this we're constantly jumping back and
forth between front-end and back-end
code here and again in
if you would have a kind of
well
i wouldn't maybe say typical but
stereotypical
development setup where you have the
front end and the back end separated
then each of one of these back and forth
would probably be
an hour of meetings to agree on on how
should we do things
and that that's kind of what we want to
avoid here
all right so i'm going to actually set
up a little in-memory database for us so
that we can like see the whole thing
from from database to to view layer
so all right
and at the same time what
yeah go ahead so i'm adding an h2
database dependency and
spring boot starter jpa and that
probably a
good reminder that we are in fact in a
spring boot application here
yep
um
yeah and and and
and we're using spring boot because it's
it's the refactor standard right now in
in the
in the back end world and and we we kind
of we really appreciate how it gives you
access to everything
basically in the java ecosystem you have
immediate access it's kind of
more common that not not that there's
already a spring boot integration with
it which means that you don't need to
care about any configuration at all
unless you really want to so for
instance here we got the database we got
the jpi integration everything actually
we're not using those those yet but
they are there immediately configured
without anything extra from our side
some things that i do want to configure
in our data model here i want to make
some kind of validation constraints so
for instance the name
should not be blank right so we have to
like actually add something and if we
add something we probably want a
non-negative
amount of those right
yeah
i mean yeah
if it shouldn't be negative then the
minimum value is one i guess
that
i think your math is correct yeah
good job
yep
then we'll
generate some boilerplate
like that
and that gives us a
data model now
to access the database
we'll use a just a spring data
repository so we'll call this
grocery policy
and this will be an interface
that
extends from the
va
repository and here we give two types
here so the first one is the grocery
item and the second one is the
type
id
right are you happy with that did i do
something horribly wrong hopefully not
it looks great uh you might want to add
not null also to those but maybe we we
can manage without that
yeah uh yeah i like to live dangerously
all right so let's do it that way
uh
so since we are in a spring application
we can probably auto wire in things into
our endpoint here to kind of get access
to the rest of the application
we will do a
constructor
inject
injection here so we'll take the
grocery story
repo i'll call it repo because typing
repository and talking at the same time
is surprisingly difficult
yep and
and like we see also here like these
endpoints they are
full-blown spring beans you can
auto wire things in okay you don't even
need to mention auto wired hair but it
it does everything you would expect from
from spring spring beans
we've got a couple of questions while
marcus is typing
simple things here
uh
norbert
herzeg
is asking what are your expectations
with regards to large projects what's
the ideal repository set up which can
support multiple people or maybe
multiple teams working on the same
application
so this goes back to
a little bit what i said about
the next version that we're working on
would would use byte code instead of
java as the primary thing for the
type strip generation and that in itself
will enable a multi-module setup because
otherwise you would have to do really
weird things to help the generator find
the java sources but with
with the upcoming version
uh we should we we will enable and and
also document how you do a multi-module
maven setup so that different parts of
the application can be worked on in in
separate places and still bringing
everything together
so what have you done now i guess we
don't see any difference
no so well one thing i realized i had to
do was restart the server since we added
some dependencies to our palm and i
failed to do that earlier so i had to do
that
but in addition to that i
used this
injected repo here to expose two methods
one for just finding
all the grocery items that we have
and one for saving
and
then i added some of these non-nulls
maybe you can talk a little bit about
why we
wanted to add those
yeah that that's an interesting it it's
been a struggle we there there's no good
way because in java we have one default
that things can be null and then in on
the typescript side there's kind of the
opposite default that if if you don't
have any knowledge then everything is
so much easier to do
so uh
to to make those two ends
worlds meet we we have to do it so that
if you don't have non-null there then
the typescript type
will be be that it it might be null and
then you will end up with lots of
warnings or errors so so that's what we
we're explicitly saying also to the java
side that that we don't expect anything
to be now there
good
so
i'm back in the view here and
let's jump into some reactive
coding that's always fun right
so i'm going to define a state
for our component
and while i'm typing again you can maybe
explain what's going on
yep
so
reactive here means kind of that
whenever the data here changes
so when the grocery items
uh instance field changes then uh the
the lit element base class that actually
the view class
inherits from it will automatically take
care of rendering
a new version of the template
that
in a really efficient way just changes
things that actually depend on the state
so we're not using that state yet in any
of the code you're typing but we'll get
there really soon
about that
kind of
reactive approach uh it's it's very much
the standard way if you are building
anything with with front-end
technologies
today so all the frameworks have that
nowadays but if you for instance compare
it with
uh with server-side rendering for
instance timely leaf templates or
something then it's it's quite a
difference because uh with this we don't
need to do a separate round trip to the
server every time something changes but
instead it's just a very very small
incremental change
and that again it's it's kind of
it's making everything smoother
especially for the end users when they
don't need to to wait for the page to
reload
yeah so maybe i can explain a little bit
what i typed here while you were talking
so yeah we have the state here so we're
saying essentially our grocery items
uh state
will be of type grocery item array so
that's something that was automatically
generated for us because we exposed it
from the endpoint
we start off with just having an empty
array of no grocery items
and then in the template here the
template's always kind of
what's shown in the view is always just
a
kind of a function of the state so we're
saying that the grid should always show
as its items whatever we have in the
grocery items and if we change what's in
the grocery items then the grid will
update accordingly right
yep
right and then i'm going to go here to
the connected callback which
is called whenever we actually uh
instantiate this view and add it to the
dom and
now we can get to that
async that you were talking about so
there's an easier way perhaps to kind of
work with asynchronous code by using
this async and a weight so we can say
that this dot
grocery items will be equal to a weight
so we
wait for the answer to come back and
then we
assign this so it looks like we're doing
just kind of
uh sequential code but under the hood
this will kind of
uh non-blockingly wait for for the end
point to to return so we'll call the
grocery endpoint
import that
and then we'll call find all just
initialize with whatever we have in the
database when we start now of course we
don't have anything there yet so i think
for that we need to
fix this whole form so we have a way of
adding
things
so for that we're going to create a
binder
that will be a new
binder
takes making two things
the element that contains the form and
then
this grocery
story item model so what's the
difference between the the model and the
grocery item itself
well the main thing is that the model is
it's just metadata it's it's kind of
it's
it describes
it's a json object ish that describes
what what are the actual properties in
this thing and also with with a whole
bunch of fancy typescript magic to for
for us to be able to autocomplete things
and so on
yeah
so here we get to actual magic
for for this sphere or
for the body number field we we use or
for both of the fields we use the field
directive that's a lit feature
and
and we just tell which part of the model
of this binder is it that this thing is
and the model that's less than the
grocery item model that we
got got from this dot binder a couple of
lines up which we in turn passed into
the binder yeah so let's yeah i guess we
need a way to kind of trigger the
validation and that happens i think when
we try to submit so we still need to
kind of hook up this button
but you can already see there's like a
little dot here indicating that this is
a required field so can't beat blank
we must have more than one
item so we can see that some of those
validations that we defined
in our java model are already being
applied here
yep
right and then the way the way that
works is that it's actually when you
have that
that
servers are entity the grocery item
model that is generated typescript based
on that class it also contains
information about those validation
annotations which means that you
automatically get typescript
you get client-side validation
automatically based on
on the server-side java rules that you
have
so while you're talking what i did was i
bound the click event of the button to
this dot add item and then here i
started
uh kind of implementing this so i'm
telling the binder to submit the form to
our endpoint so we're call it grocery
and point
the save method there and if you
remember the
save method takes in a grocery item so
the types match up there
and then if we get back a
saved item
oh yep so typescript saved the world
here
because oh you forgot to actually assign
that to it to the promise and not to the
value returned from the promise when
it's completed so i would have had a bug
in my code if i
if typescript hadn't told me that i'm
being dumb
all right so if we do get a
item back what we can do is we can
append it
to this array now how the change
detection works is that it actually
looks at the reference so if we just did
kind of what might be
the initial thought that you have so we
take we would take like this that
grocery items dot push and we would add
the saved here that wouldn't actually
re-render because that's still it's just
looking at which instance of an array is
attached here so what we actually want
to do is we want to
quickly create a new array with
all the
all the items that we had from before
and then the saved item appended to it
like this
and then we can also tell
binder
to clear itself so that we're ready to
import
this item
so this should work now do is that what
we think life
i i think it hopes i used to say that if
you type
java
if you type java and it compiles then it
works
and the same also goes with typescript
apparently yeah
thanks
i don't like to buy full cartons of eggs
just prefer odd numbers of eggs
that's the way we roll it
all right so that worked uh do you think
we can
reload yeah so we can actually reload
this to
show that it's coming from the database
so when we
restart or reload the ui
it's calling this endpoint to find
everything in the database initialize
yeah
we've got a bunch of questions that
could be quite great to take at this
moment also
yeah shoot
we got ricardo legoreza who asked do you
have any ex do you have an example for
spring authorization server o oauth2
with what inhaler
i guess that's what we have if you go to
healer.dev docs and in the menu there's
security so that shows
in integrating with uh
with spring security and it uses uh
all the fancy jwt stuff and and such as
behind the scenes go to this stateless
authentication
section four
okay yeah that's the jwt stuff
yeah
but that that should
should describe what what you're
asking about then we got actually a
whole bunch of questions
about grid does it support
the grid also supports data provider
instead of items does it also support
lazy loading unknown size same as flow
dust
and then there's other grid questions
does grid support pagination
and does grid support lazy loading and
prefetch
so yes the simple example we showed here
uses
an in-memory list of items with the grid
you can also use a data provider so just
give it
callbacks to
to to fetch data
it also because it's really it's the
same grid that you use with body flow so
it's it supports all the same things you
just
configure it from from typescript
instead of from from java and you got
all the same features
pagination isn't one of the features
uh
yeah so so there you have a video on how
to do that
exactly
i guess this is with hila also although
i guess the video is
it's with fusion which
is probably good to mention that this
used to be called vod infusion up until
last week so
you can still find a lot of relevant
content if you
if you look for that
yeah
the grid doesn't do pagination you can
do that
manually there's even an add-on in the
body directory for it
but yes it does support lazy loading
with the kind of
infinite scrolling approach you can just
keep scrolling and scrolling and
scrolling it just fetches more and more
data
it pre-fetches
that was also one of the questions it
pre-fetches a bunch of of rows ahead
also so that in most cases you won't
ever even notice that it loads anything
yeah all right i think there were some
questions right now
yeah well there was kind of a
sort of
a question that touched on another
question like
uh does this work the same way as flow
does so maybe you want to
talk a little bit about what's the kind
of relationship between the
the two frameworks that we now have in
and how they're related to each other
um
yeah before we get rid of that i want to
talk about another thing actually um
because what we've been kind of
summarizing what we've been seeing here
so far
is that
by
combining typescript and java mostly
generating typescript code from java
code
what we have is something that
really really optimizes
the productivity of developers
because one of the things one of the
reasons we built tila also is that
we
we really believe that when you build
typical so to say business applications
then
you have lots and lots and lots of use
cases you have basically lots of
lots of business processes that need to
be covered
and at the same time you typically don't
have terrible many users you have kind
of hundreds thousands maybe tens of
thousands of users
but probably not a billion users like
you would have if you would be building
the next netflix or something
and that means that
we can really optimize so that
productivity of the developer that's the
most important thing and it's not like
we say that it's not at all important to
be efficient on the server and so on but
it's it's not the top most priority and
that's something that is specifically
for
building business type of web
applications
and this is something we have learned
throughout the years from building vodka
flow
the framework for
for doing exactly this kind of
application but only with java instead
and we continue building both flow and
hilla side by side and actually to be
honest
flow is the bigger
focus of for us from an engineering
point of view even though right now
today when he lies new that's that's
where where our focus is kind of here
here on on the webinar and so on but
still we're very much still also working
with with flow to
to help all those people who who
who want to build these business web
applications using only java and and
well you can optimize things with with
some front-end stuff also but it's it's
it's not in any way necessary yeah well
i think the one of the big benefits
of of this new kind of split that we
have where hilla lives in one place and
flo lives in another
is that we can kind of both teams in a
way can focus really on exactly those
things that are relevant
for those users and also kind of in
terms of when you're searching for
information as as you're developing if
you're
like previously if you looked for volume
binder you could depending on seo you
could find either the flow binder or the
fusion binder and that was a little bit
of
kind of confusion if you will
if you pardon the pun
uh
but now of course if you search for
hilla binder you will immediately find
just the helidocs and and that also
means like when you're here in the docs
and you do command k and you start
searching for i don't know
login this is all scoped just to this
one framework which again makes it
easier to just kind of stay in that
place where you are right than what
you're interested in doing
uh of course we are still kind of
support the hybrid use case where you
might want to add a couple of
either like client-side views to a
server-side flow application or the
other way around
but for the most part we believe that
people will kind of fall into mainly one
or one or the other camp
that's right
i'm seeing we have one more question
that
i haven't
answered and that's from peter sykes who
asks where can i get the book of gila
right now the book of hillary's is the
duck site so um
i'd really kind of recommend going here
like it's there's still definitely
things that we need to kind of
improve here but i think especially the
tutorial section is quite
in-depth already we have a full-blown
tutorial showing you how to build a
fully functional crm application that
works offline for most part kind of
deals with some relationships and and
kind of
displaying data in different ways using
application state management through
mobx and kind of touches on
kind of going from that
kind of initial hello world one
one kind of view application to a more
meaningful big application
so there's a lot of a lot of good stuff
here already in the in the hello docs
yep uh now we have martin lopez asking
what about the road map what are the
biggest things that you're working right
now that will save the future future of
the library
as i mentioned
the the very next thing is the the new
typescript generator that that uses
bytecode instead of java sources as the
primary source and that would then also
enable multi-module support among other
things
another big thing i i mean in general we
think that hila does everything you need
right now
one thing that that we have been talking
about very much is to get server push
support
so so that you can also from the server
send
updates to to the client without having
to have the client ask for them
so that's another big thing that we that
we plan to get
get under development we had a really
really good prototype
on twitter just yesterday about that
also
yeah it's a
good mention here so if you subscribe to
the hila framework
twitter account you'll you'll find a
link to that
cool prototype with the server push or
kind of reactive end points if you will
yep
and now we've got lots of queen
questions here
good
um confuse everyone life good job
what
yeah okay yeah
yeah i didn't answer all the questions
up front
so we have uh andreas moshke who asks
what are the plans with what in design
system publisher with still build a
design system which contains both flow
and hilar documentation
that's an excellent question i guess so
we haven't discussed it but
probably yes
because we are also
i mean we are using the same design
system publisher for doing the the
component documentation on variant.com
where we show for instance dividing grid
both for typescript and for java users
so yeah i guess
i guess
it won't change
yeah
and
do you know the lightweight cloud
hosting solution where you can just drop
a button
bundle and start serving web content
um
i don't know maybe you know marcus
um i think
the the closest that comes to mind is
heroku very straightforward to just kind
of use either the cli or set up a github
kind of workflow that just publishes
apps and uh
yeah i think hill apps have
they start up pretty quickly there's not
as much i think kind of going on as they
start up so they're even though heroku
is quite aggressive at kind of spinning
down
servers they they do get up pretty fast
do you think uh kind of speaking of
getting started quick do you think like
uh supporting things like spring native
might be on the
roadmap or even like just investigation
type of
roadmap for for hillah
potentially yes i mean
we really really want to listen to what
what the users want to have and so far
i don't remember anyone specifically
saying that that they would be in
particular interested in spreading i did
i am somebody
i don't know if you count as a user
but it's
it's certainly a possibility it really
depends on how much interest there is in
in different possibilities there i don't
see any architectural reason for why it
wouldn't wouldn't work
yeah and uh
i think
kind of related to our earlier
development deployment discussion roland
was asking
if he understood correctly that there's
no need for http session
with hilla and that you essentially can
write stateless hill applications and
that is correct
yep
what about hill and corkers we get a
question from victors here
uh it's really the same as with
with spring native it's
we don't have any specific plans for it
it really depends on
we could always say that it's a battle
is there more interest for quarkus or
spring native
and and based on
whichever is more interested or people
is more interested in then that's
probably the one we would be building
first so for for quercus actually it's
slightly ahead because there is a github
issue here if you go to the faq
and click on this github issue here you
can go and
thumb up this issue to kind of help
signal to us that this is something that
would be interesting to you and and of
course like
hearing from people and getting signals
on what's in interesting and important
to you is something that can help us
focus our efforts on on the right things
yep
we're getting more questions here
i am working with vadim 14 will this
this work with it
no it won't uh
this this um
this used to be vod infusion which
was added in what in 15
and then has been growing since then
starting from volume 23 that will be
released
next week no two weeks no next week
actually i think
it gila will be a standalone thing so it
kind of follows the same version release
cycle but it's a separate thing you can
very easily integrate them
but
with volume 14 there isn't a good way of
integrating them so
so kind of they wouldn't clash but you
would have a hard time using them
together in to get one unified
ui that uses some views you from hell
and some from yeah
i guess the
the kind of good news though is that
going from bottom 14 to 23 and
kind of getting access to being able to
use a hilla
hybrid app is fairly straightforward
there weren't that many breaking changes
between
14 and 23 in terms of the java api
yep
all right did we have any more questions
or should we start wrapping up here
i think i see one more question
how could
you build a configurable app
for instance config configurable grid
columns renderers and more would you
fetch the config from an endpoint in
render
uh
yeah
well not in render but in the
connected callback that that marcus
already showed that's a good place to
fetch it you could also for that kind of
use case if it's really application wide
you could just fetch it once in
index.html index ds and then export it
from there and then you can import the
configuration in all the places you need
it
or then you could use mobx that we have
documented in the
in the documentation to have all those
things in a store so that you would get
updates for them and so on also
yeah then we got a last minute question
kind of getting us full circle back to
where we started how about end points
rest
yep
so that goes to the back ends for front
ends thing
if you look at what what you have with
hill i
kind of inspect the demo application we
built uh in the network inspector you
will see that it it very much
looks like rest
but we we haven't we we don't want to
make it complicated to create endpoints
we don't want to force you to define
that this is the path this is a post
parameter this is a get parameter and so
on
so
we're not offering that configurability
instead we would recommend that if you
want to have a third party
rest client to to access your backend
yeah there we see and actually if you
zoom in we see that it actually also
goes to
do a save url well actually we don't see
that anywhere
yeah okay
well it's somewhere there but but yeah
in any way it kind of looks like the
rest but we haven't made it configurable
so that you can define your own
uh
api schema there so instead definitely
recommend using
spring mvc or
rest controller or or anything like that
to build a dedicated rest api for
particularly the things that
the rest clients would need
good
oh no questions start flowing in do we
have time still or should we let's let's
answer one more question and then we'll
kind of do the rest we'll
i'll put another banner up here to
tell people to come to our discord
server and continue the discussion there
any time so let's take one more one more
question uh and then we'll start
wrapping up here
the next one in line would be
kerberos integration forwarding question
mark
not really it would be really great to
have but also the challenge is that
everyone's kerberos integration is
different than anyone else's
so it's it's very much custom there
you can in general follow the
the kind of the same principle that you
would use
in the authentication documentation it
should be possible to also use that for
kerberos but uh
i'm afraid we don't even have an example
on that
good
i think the
the last question we had was such a
short one then i'll just say that if you
want to create custom components what we
use ourselves and all the views are
based on on this lit library so lit.dev
contains all the all the kind of
in-depth uh instructions and playgrounds
and stuff for how to build
standards-based web components using
using lit all right but let's start
wrapping up here
there's another half of that question
using flow
so you can integrate with flow also
good all right yeah i somehow
miss that part of the question but
anyway
uh yeah thanks a lot lei for coming here
i think it was really
kind of instructional to to see
both the code but understand kind of
what are the kind of design decisions
that are behind that like why did you
build things that specific way and what
are the thoughts about having a front
end and back end so tightly integrated
as opposed to like completely
separate things and and i think just
having those components there as an
additional layer
just makes things a lot quicker because
i can just tell a grid here's a list of
things i want you to show
and it shows them so i don't have to go
and search for another
kind of third-party grid and see how how
do i integrate that into my specific
stack it's all there so i can focus more
on like how do i actually build the
functionality that i need in my
application
yeah so to summarize
why we built hila we built it because we
believe in
feature teams
using the back-end for front-end pattern
to build
business applications
with spring boot
in a way that prioritizes developer
productivity
easy
good and i think one of the things you
mentioned in your blog post too that's
kind of worth mentioning is that we
kind of we see that a lot of our our
users for hillary will be people
building these kind of business
applications like you mentioned kind of
business critical applications and and
hilla is is supported by vauden the same
way as as floyd so if you do need
uh enterprise support
hands-on help kind of extended
maintenance or warranty or anything
that is something that you can get for
hillar as well so it is a kind of fully
production ready and supported framework
yep
perfect well thank you leif thanks
everyone for joining it was a good
webinar again uh i let us know what you
have if you have any ideas for
new topics or things that you'd like to
see uh we're gonna try to start creating
some more content in terms of like
tutorials and videos and stuff so
share your ideas with us so we know
to kind of create the right kind of
content so yeah
thanks everyone and goodbye
thank you bye